[Music]
okay everybody so i am so excited today
because
i am joined by the man the myth the
legend charlie cox aka michael kinsella
in the new amc plus crime drama kin
how you doing today uh charlie i'm good
thanks steve how's it going
good man so i was lucky enough to watch
the show already i absolutely love it of
course you crush it here so my first
question for you though is for a big
name actor like yourself what's like the
main draw what what brought you into
this project
you know it's a funny set of
circumstances actually my um my wife was
one of the producers on the show and i
was i was scheduled to do some other
stuff in 2020.
um and she asked me if i'd be interested
to read this
small irish show that she was producing
and i read it and i was i was so moved
by it i was so impressed by it and i
kind of found myself wanting to play a
number of the characters
um
and then you know the my the show that i
was filming fell through and there was
we were presented with the opportunity
to go to ireland as a family and stay
together during covid and and i would
get to work on this
this amazing
show this amazing piece of writing and
so it kind of it just kind of all fell
into place really nicely
yeah that sounds really cool and i
that's cool that you kind of get like an
intimate experience with the show you're
working on i think that's pretty awesome
and that your wife's also part of the
industry um
about family and so it was kind of it
was it was quite serendipitous
yeah and speaking of it being about
family it reminds me of like an irish
version version of the sopranos a bit
yeah yeah
i'm i'm wondering though is charlie cox
like are you a big fan of crime drama
shows like sopranos the wire do you
watch any of those
do of course you know um you know i
watch your shows um but you know i like
to i i like to kind of semi joke that
this is a mixture of
uh the sopranos and normal people
you know because we've got the you've
got the the crime family element
but but also what i loved about normal
people was just how
so much would have so much could happen
when nothing was happening
you know you feel so much just from a
look between two people and
and and that's what i think they've
tried to do with this show with kin is
that is that you've got this crime
family and these big stakes and these
scary situations but so much of our show
lives in the
the interesting dynamics and
relationships between the characters
in the family and how one person says
one thing and how it impacts the whole
the whole family and blah blah blah
yeah no for sure and like you're saying
about
how each character says one thing
there's such good dialogue in this show
between all of you guys and what really
impresses me is that you're an english
actor who usually has to do american
accents so now you're doing an irish
accent is there a pressure you feel all
the time being around people who kind of
naturally have an irish accent they're
like oh okay i hope i'm nailing this
like what oh man yeah yeah
the first few days are awful
you know
the first few days when you do it in
front of people and you
like you're just worrying that
everyone's like oh [ __ ] that's not good
um so you know you hope that you
you know i work really hard i try and do
it as much as possible and
and then the rest is like you just you
hope that you that you you hope for the
best basically
yeah and and you and it shows you work
really hard and i feel like you're
always taking on challenging roles so
your most recently challenging role i
would say people mostly know you for is
obviously daredevil matt murdock and him
being
blind did that experience of playing a
blind character
kind of change your approach to playing
non-blind characters like does it seem
easier now like is there some kind of
thing you learned from that you know i
was really excited to to be able to act
again on screen and you and use my eyes
yeah
to convey emotion etc
um and it was really fun to do that you
know i was really i felt like i was
given back something
right right
like a tool
but i also noticed that you the
that
in many ways not being able to use your
eyes as an actor
also freed me up in ways i hadn't i
hadn't realized at the time
you know because
because you you
you know where as matt murdock not using
his eyes meant that he could
he could get away with things
more because because other characters
can't
look into my eyes and tell if i'm lying
you know yeah
no that that's so interesting yeah i
feel like you could have a conversation
about that for days it's fascinating
stuff but it's it's amazing that you can
do both and you're so versatile with
that and i'm wondering too with your
character michael in the show
do you feel more of a sense of freedom
and leeway with character choices you
make because
usually crime drama shows they're based
off like real people but this is a
fictional story so did you did you kind
of get this character from scratch how
did that even like come about
well he's on paper you know i re i read
the episodes and i i they were so well
constructed they were so compelling and
interesting and the character was there
so you know my job is at first is just
to kind of try and get in
in peter to create his head space and
make sure that i'm that i'm
understanding who who michael is to him
and then once i feel like i'm close to
that you know i
have more conversations about it and try
and make it my own a little bit and
you know we would talk about
you know when a new script would come in
if there was something i didn't quite
understand or i felt differently about
we would talk about it but for the most
part you know he's so talented that
it really was just about
about
you know being
bringing what he wrote to life as best
as possible
so with that process though and you
saying how you're speaking with the
writers and directors
what do you have a specific technique as
an actor are you a method actor are you
kind of just switch it up each time are
you loosey-goosey with it
yeah i think so i mean
you know i
um i
i mean i don't i don't really know what
method means and i i think that's kind
of it's kind of a loose term and i think
it make a lot of us kind of think of
daniel day-lewis when we think of method
i certainly don't i certainly don't do
that
but i do like to create a mood
i do like to kind of
create
a world that makes me feel like the
person a little bit
you know and i'll and i'll
you know you i kind of have an instinct
about what feels like michael versus
what feels like charlie
um
and i it's kind of an esoteric thing as
well i don't really know what it is but
like yeah i i
i feel like when you're building the
character you know i'm reading the
scripts a lot i'm doing my research and
i'm just slowly gaining more knowledge
and more insight to a point where i feel
like
oh and i know how this guy feels now
and yeah and then and then once you get
there it's just about spending as much
time in that place as possible so that
when you're acting
you can you can be free and and you can
have a kind of almost an instinctual
response to something that is
that is true to the character but
wouldn't necessarily be true to you the
actor
sure and i think that's interesting
about this part of michael is that he's
very
more quiet reserved role so i'm guessing
what you're saying about being
instinctual is that also kind of
challenging when you have to dial it
back a bit right like that's not this
right character with all these lines
because that's not who i am like i'm i'm
much more kind of talkative and
kind of you know outgoing and and
um enthusiastic than
than michael is so sometimes it's quite
freeing to be like oh wow this is how
other people
live and i should do that more often
because it's so much more you know like
it's it's more relaxing
no that that's awesome and here's kind
of a random question of the show too
when i was watching these screeners for
it i noticed there's giant snakes on set
here i'd be freaking out were you
freaking out are you cool with that
stuff like you dig that
i i was pretty cool with it i didn't i
chose not to be one of the people that
had the big snake around my neck
i i didn't want to do that
but
but i was i was okay i was okay around
it it's pretty intimidating
yeah no i would imagine because i always
wanted that kind of stuff like are you
just getting character to not be afraid
of it or you're naturally not afraid it
seems like you're cool with that stuff
when they're when they're in the when
they're in there like they're not cage
whatever you call it yeah when they're
in i feel okay
okay okay good um
and i would it would be a sin for me not
to bring this up and ask but you know i
just want just your thoughts like do you
get a kick out of seeing your name
trending on twitter all week and like
people breaking down theories about you
being in the next fighter movie does
that you gonna throw other you kind of
just not pay attention to it
so i'm not on social media so i don't i
don't i don't have the same awareness
about it as probably other people do but
obviously i hear about it you know my my
my mom will tell me about it and my wife
is aware of it all that kind of stuff
yeah i see it as a massive massive
it makes me feel very grateful that
people care
that much
um
you know i
i also
like
like it makes
you know i don't
i wouldn't want to ruin something either
way like
do you know what i mean like so
so
it makes me a little anxious in that
regard
you know because
so it's a difficult you know so it's
difficult thing to talk about you know
all i would say is like
i guess
everyone myself included is just going
to have to wait and see what happens
yeah and it's just cool because it shows
how beloved you are as daredevil so oh
it's awesome that you have that like
power and people want to see you again
but um everyone if you want to see
charlie cox again you got to watch canon
premieres next thursday september 9th on
amc plus i have watched all of it it is
incredible and charlie crushes here as
michael can sell you're not going to
miss it charlie thank you so much for
joining me today and i hope i appreciate
you man thank you so much
bye